uh it has been tough years for
hong kong people and of course
especially for
the staff of apple daily and
i feel very very sad about what has
happened
but that makes my life meaningful
i joined april daily in 2012
it has been the ninth year as i work in
apple daily
[Music]
so
apple daily focuses a lot on human
rights political issues
and freedom of speech fairness
social justice so when you are talking
about political news
those values are very important not to
apple daily but to hong kong
[Music]
it's very heartbroken for me
to cover news like that
because it concerns my own company
concerns with the newspaper
any concerns with the whole press in
hong kong
i think what i can do is just to
document everything
[Music]
i see
foreign
don't try to accuse the hong kong
authorities for using the national
security law
as a tool to suppress the media or to
stifle the freedom
of expression
[Applause]
[Applause]
photos
[Music]
i believe in the future the government
is trying to targeting a different news
media
and it symbolizes that that we
have lost our freedom yeah there will
still be
newspaper there will still be press in
hong kong
but knowing
no one is there enough to to report
political news no one is going to
comment
against the government the ccp
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
these nine years will definitely be the
practice moment in my life
i wish i could still
use the identity or photographer
to document everything
you